حرب اليمن تأخذ من أولئك الذين
يستطيعون تحمل نفقاتها ، وقد تمزقت ساق أما البالغة من العمر سبع سنوات على الأقل
بقذيفة كنت
ألعب مع أصدقائي
يخبرنا فجأة أنه حدث انفجار
قتل ثمانية من أصدقائي وأصيبت شظايا في
ساقي  وخلع الجسد ،
يريد طبيبه إنهاء المعاناة ، لكن لا أحد
هنا لديه الرفاهية للتخلي عنه ،
لقد أظهر لنا هذه الصورة
لابنه ابنه البالغ من العمر 11 عامًا ، آنا ، ترى الدماء
لا تزال تلطخ دموع العائلة حيث
مات فيها.  ذراعي الأب غاضب
ويقول إن الحوثيين لم يقتلوا
ابنه فحسب ، بل كذبوا بشأنه. هذا من
الصحيفة في الوقت الذي يقول فيه أن
الحوثيين استخدموا هذه الصورة له وهو يأخذ
ابنه ليدفن ليقول إن ابنه
قتل.  في غارة جوية للتحالف
لم تكن حقيقية جالسًا بجانبه في
ردهة الفندق ، وهو جندي انفصالي جنوبي
قاتلت لاستعادة
السيطرة على الهواء ، أخبرني أن والدته
قُتلت على يد قناص حوثي ، إنه
غاضب منهم لكنه أيضًا غاضب.  غاضب من
الحكومة المدعومة من السعودية
وحاربنا الحوثيين كما يوضح لكن
الحكومة لم تهتم بنا
ومن الصعب الاستمرار بسبب
تهميش الجنوبيين
فهم الحرب هنا التي
يمر بها الجميع
تشبه إلى حد ما تقشير طبقة بعد طبقة.
لا تقاتل الحكومة
الحوثيين فحسب ، بل تقاتل داعش
والقاعدة ، ثم هناك الانفصاليون الجنوبيون
الذين يريدون دولتهم
الخاصة والعديد من
المجموعات السياسية الصغيرة الأخرى ، وقد أحبط هؤلاء الحكام الإقليميون الأقوياء
اليمن الذي أصبح
وكيلًا للتوترات الإقليمية
التي يقولون عنها.  أنا يريدون من الحكومة
والتحالف الذي تقوده السعودية أن يصبحوا
أكثر صرامة مع المتمردين الحوثيين المدعومين من إيران ،
لكنهم يريدون أيضًا أن يقوم
التحالف بإغلاق الجماعات السياسية التي
يدعمونها ، بلطف جدًا لمقابلتك.
كيف هو الوضع هنا في عدن
رئيس وزراء اليمن محاصر  من خلال
كل الكابينة التي تؤثر بالوكالة عن الانفصاليين الجنوبيين ، فإن
الخسائر البشرية الناجمة عن
قصف التحالف تستولي على مستقبل اليمن في أ
تحالف خاسر الحوثيون يريدون الانفصال
في الشمال
والعراق الانفصالي الراديكالي يريد
جلسة في الجنوب ولكن إذا أعطيت
الشعب اليمني خيارا ستجد
أن الغالبية تريد الوحدة ولكن في شكل جديد
كفدرالية حسنا أتيت حرة.
قم بتقييد lgt لتكون علمانية
سؤالًا سريعًا قليلاً هو هل يمكن إعادة البلد
معًا ، سألت الطبيب إذا كان
الناس سيغفرون ضحايا
غارات التحالف الجوية التي تعتقد أنهم
سيكونون قادرين على مسامحة المملكة العربية السعودية إذا كانت
البلاد ستكون أفضل من ذي قبل.
كل هؤلاء الجرحى كل هذه
الادعاءات الأشخاص الذين سوف يغفرون
لهم لم يقصدوا ذلك حقًا ولكني طفلة
هذا سيكون أننا سنفتح مشروعًا
تجاريًا جديدًا بشرط أن تسير الدولة في اتجاه
إيجابي ، نعم إنه التسامح في
المستقبل الذي لا يمكن أن يأتي بسرعة  بما يكفي
للعديد مما ننظر إليه هنا ،
فقد قام هذان الطالبان
بطلب الطابعة عبر الإنترنت من الصين ، وتعلما
كيفية استخدامها من خلال مشاهدة دروس YouTube التعليمية
التي يريدان إصلاحها في بلدهما
جاهز وأعمل أنا لا أهتم بالقضايا السياسية
نريد الحناجر نريد التعليم
نريد الحصول على وظائف إنه حلم أن
القطعة الغائبة لا تزال بعيدة عن متناول NIC
روبرتسون CNN اليمن